people are surprised that MIT has a
public art program and it's been going
on since 1965 really we think of the
entire campus as a museum and we have
over 66 large-scale permanent art
install throughout campus we are known
to be a technology school however ever
since world war ii mit has really
thought of the arts as important both in
terms of curricular but also in the life
on campus and the life of the students
Alexander Calder's the big sail from
1965 mi t--'s first major Commission of
public art Calder's big sail really has
this function of humanizing the post-war
MIT campus this is a term that MIT
administration used in support of why
there were Arts at MIT this idea of
humanizing scientists and technologists
president reasoner was an enormous
supporter of art at MIT and he was
integral in mi t--'s adoption of a
percent for art policy which allocates a
portion of every building project or
major renovation budget to new art in
public space on campus and this policy
was passed in 1968 by President Johnson
and Mighty's percent for art is very
rare for a private university it is the
oldest in the country and one of the
very few in 1975 the IM Pei chemistry
building was first percent for art
program and that was a Louise Nevelson I
am Pei suggested Nevelson as the artists
to create a work for the newly built
building 66 and it is her second public
art Commission she had just started
working at that scale when the work was
installed he was actually placed in the
students volleyball court and students
had no idea this was happening and
students became quite irritated and a
series of hacks ensued we learned a
valuable lesson with that so we do
involve students now in our process what
I find so exciting and fantastic about
MIT is in a way we collect art and
architecture so as you walk around you
are surrounded by creativity and
physical presence apart building like
the Frank Gehry building estado which is
any artificial intelligence and computer
science building or the Steven Hall
building which is a residence it really
is just an amazing gift to the visitors
Dan Graham's mingyang pavilion is from
2003 it takes the form of a very large
yin yang students have really engaged
with the piece in a very MIT way they
place small rubber ducks in the water
portion of the work which can be a
challenge in terms of maintaining the
work but the artist actually really
enjoys this gesture of interaction on
the part of this too
for those who know about the MIT percent
for our program in the public art
collection it is considered world class
but one of the messages we want to get
out is that most Bostonians don't know
that this public art exists here and
it's free always open to the public and
so we want everyone to know about the
collection